okay oh okay
I guess that's why they call it murder
clown oh hi everybody my name is Martha
buyer totally forgot
I literally just woke up and I started
playing this game I don't even know if
it can be called a game okay um this
game is called murder clown I it was on
gamejolt and hi again
hello mr. clown man how are you do okay
goodbye
skipping on bail is going on literally
have no okay I'm just as confused as you
guys are I don't know what's happening
right now I'm not even sure I like it
what's going on why I'm assuming because
the game in game is murder clown that
I'm capturing these people and murdering
them in my sack of happiness that I'm
carrying over there what would happen if
for instance we google a bunch of goats
and so I'm on the screen James and Joe
Cox I'm assuming you're the developers
of this game and one of you with that
clown guy oh good is that a city or a
train I can't tell why am i capturing
the same people why am i in a clown's
mouth why is this happening
what is going on I've got so many
questions I don't know what's happening
right now I think I like it
I'm not entirely sure what is going on I
don't know why oh crap
got my cup oh I didn't make it all the
way all things are subject to
interpretation whichever interpretation
prevails at a given time is a-ok Thank
You Fredrik nice
mr. clown man you look happy - okay my
underwater now I'm assuming that that's
underwater mspaint back there a ton of
examining why am i recording this I
don't even know god is so going in my
not upload pile I'm a whole folder of
videos that I made that are designated
do not uploads and upon my death they
will all be released and you will see
the kind of absurdity that I've had to
experience in the past and I don't even
know about this one this it has this
sort of charm that I can't even
interpret I do not have much patience
with a thing of beauty that must be
explained to be understood if it does
need an additional interpretation by
someone other than the creator then I
question whether it has fulfilled its
purpose
wise words from Charlie Chaplin um okay
we're in a rush on the last one now
you're not going anywhere
hello it's way too early in the morning
to be dealing with this I'm not ready
hey oh hey hi again how are you doing
yeah I screaming flowers and submarines
and stars look oh it's over oh I'm done
apparently I just got mine [ __ ] then I
don't know what happened it's early in
the morning for this [ __ ] okay
that's the end hope you guys enjoyed it
I think I just dropped like 50 IQ points
I don't know what I'm gonna do with my
life now it's been turned flipped upside
down shut up but Fitz
here you go everybody if you saw this
then it exists so thank you all so much
for watching and as always I'll see you
in the next video you already know
what's gonna come in the splash screen
it's gonna be penis cloner so click on
that and do it bye everybody